Salut, il y a quelques temps
Michaël Hirsch, qui était déjà passé sur la chaîne
et qui fait des vidéos qui s'appellent Lettres ou ne pas lettres
m'as proposé de faire un feat avec lui,
d'aller tourner une vidéo avec lui.
Ce sont des vidéos particulières, c'est la 1ère fois que je vais faire une vidéo comme ça.
Et je me suis dit qu'il y avait peut être un intérêt à vous faire voir les coulisses de ce tournage
alors là je suis prêt. Je vais me taper une ligne de métro entière
Et je vous emmène avec moi, je serais un petit peu moins seul
*Générique*
La 1ère étape d'un tournage,
ça commence souvent par 1h de métro
et là je viens de faire toute la ligne 3,
en entier, du début à la fin
C'est impeccable
Et ça y est, j'ai enfin, au bout d'1h30, d'arrivé chez Michaël Hirsch,
Alors, si ça ne vous parle pas je vous mets un insert tout de suite
C'est exactement ça son décor
et en plus c'est pas du tout un insert
puisque je suis dans le décor, directement
Tu vois
Là, par exemple je peux vous dire que ça c'est en 3D
Ça existe réellement,
Regarde, je peux toucher
le... c'est un chat ou un chien? C'est un chat?
Michaël: C'est un chat
F: C'est un chat
M: Faut d'ailleurs que je lui trouve un nom
F: Trouvons un nom
Trouvez un nom pour le chat de Michaël Hirsch
vous pouvez me dire dans les commentaires,
quels noms que vous voulez qu'on donne au chat de Michaël Hirsch
Alors, pour vous remettre un petit peu le trucs en perspectives
Quand Michaël m'as proposé de faire la vidéo, ben tu parles j'étais ravi évidemment
Et... il a cherché le thème de la vidéo
et, tu as décidé que c'était la mémoire
M: Exactement
Et quand il a décidé que c'était la mémoire,
on a longuement parlé au téléphone,
on s'est appelé plusieurs fois
et on a passé des minutes, voire des heures
à discuter de la mémoire ensemble,
Et au delà même de la mémoire
ou des trucs que je peux donner sur la mémoire dans les vidéos ou ailleurs
Là, c'était vraiment notre rapport à la mémoire
J'ai pas encore découvert tout le texte
Je vais découvrir ça et le rôle que j'ai à y jouer
Et voilà comment ça se passe un feat
on arrive et on sait pas tout
et j'ai hâte de découvrir
quand je vois les accessoires je suis stressé
*Rire de Michaël*
*Fabien ri*
Donc quand même avant de tourner
ça serait bien que j'en sache un petit peu plus
mais je vous ai gardé avec moi pour que vous voyez ce que ça donne un brief avant un tournage
M: Donc on est sur un lettre ou ne pas lettre classique
avec toujours les 2 plans
et avec le personnage intermédiaire, c'est ce personnage là...
F: Que moi je fais
M: ...que je voudrais que tu fasses, exactement
La lettre ou ne pas lettre, c'est une lettre sur la mémoire
ça, tu le sais on en a déjà parlé ensemble
Et du coup, j'ai vraiment accès,
la lettre ou ne pas lettre sur le rapport qu'on a à notre mémoire
et le rapport
un peu conflictuel, qu'on peut avoir entre mémoire et technologie
Je te propose
d'incarner
un Jedi
Oubli-Wan Kenobi
F: C'est vrai
F: Oubli-Wan Kenobi
tu n'entends que le son de ma voix *fiou*
C'était K2000 mon *fiou fiou*
M: Ouais
F: Oubli-Wan Kenobi
M: Ouais tu as fait un featuring de série
F: C'est ça
M: Et c'est le texte que tu vois là bas exactement
et alors l'idée
C'est qu'en fait
Cette lettre, elle est un peu particulière
parce que, je trouve que...
L'idée de base c'est de dire que l'on a un rapport à notre mémoire
qui est comme une sorte de rapport de couple
F: D'accord
M: C'est à dire qu'on a vraiment quelque chose de très intime entre nous et notre mémoire
et l'idée c'est de dire que
petit à petit
à cause des nouvelles technologies
et bien on se perd un peu de vue
et on s'éloigne
et du coup c'est une lettre qui est assez tendre
et... je vais pas dire triste
mais un peu mélancolique
F: OK
M: Et du coup, ce que je trouvais assez drôle c'est que ce personnage d'Oubli-Wan Kenobi
il soit assez martial
pour justement casser
et amener un truc un peu comique là dedans
et vraiment qu'on est
une surprise à chaque fois qu'il apparaît
F: Et c'est vraiment du: "Je t'avais prévenu et tu le savais quoi"
M: Oui exactement
F: C'est bien
Oui donc, en fait, c'est plus qu'une compagne,
c'est que lui, il s'impose comme étant quelqu'un qui a des pouvoirs
et une vraie relation avec toi et que
toi tu la dénigrais et qu'aujourd'hui il dit "Tu l'as cherché aussi quoi, tu vois"
M: Exactement c'est ça
F: C'est ta responsabilité, si on s'éloigne en fait
M: Oui voilà c'est ça
F: Cool, OK
et donc je suppose que j'ai une tenue
M: Ah oui, tu as un costume. Tu es prêt?
F: Ouais
*rire de Fabien*
En même temps, je préfère être Oubli-Wan Kenobi plutôt que...
Chewbacca
par exemple, tu vois
M: C'est vrai?
F: 1er guest de la chaîne de Michaël
M: Et je suis super content
parce que je voulais que Fabien soit le 1er guest de la chaîne
du coup c'est cool parce qu'il a accepté cette vidéo et ça me fait bien plaisir
F: Et tu sais que là, ils se disent : "Ah ça doit être euh... pour la vidéo"
Non, je m'habille tous les jours comme ça
et pour la 1ère fois je le dévoile
M: Voilà, c'est pour passer incognito dans la rue
maintenant, il se déguise en Jedi
F: Ahahah c'est ça.
Vous n'avez pas vu cette vidéo
M: Tu m'en veux pas, tu vas...
ah mais oui mais bien sûr,
non mais en fait j'en ai 2 des comme ça, j'ai dû utiliser l'autre, l'autre fois
F: Ah oui tu peux régler les pieds
F: J'aimerai qu'on prenne 2 secondes, pour analyser ce qu'il vient de se passer
Michaël est en train de réduire  le tabouret
parce que je suis trop grand
PARCE QUE JE SUIS TROP GRAND
C'est à dire que depuis le début de l'année on a l'impression que je suis petit
mais on a la preuve
je suis trop grand, rien que pour ça je suis content d'être venu
moi ça me suffit
M: Tiens
F: Ah ben voilà, parce que j'étais
M&F: Trop grand
*Image du tournage en accélérée*
N.B: Il y a eu un bug sur cette vidéo, il manque toute la fin !!! le lien vers la vidéo entière est dans la description